I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, lady and everyone. Hi, everyone out there.
我是詹娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您录制独家的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉您的幕后独家故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。嗨，女士，还有大家好。嗨，外面的各位。
I'm so happy you're here listening. Jenna and I, someday we're going to come out there and take it on the road and meet you. Whoa! That's news to me. I guess we're doing it though because if Angela gets an idea, it's going to happen. I think we got to do one in Scranton, Jenna. Oh, well that's a given.
我很高兴你们在这里收听。安吉拉和我，总有一天我们会走到线下，开启巡演去见你们。哇！这对我来说可是个新闻。我想我们得去，因为安吉拉只要有了想法，就会付诸行动。我觉得我们得在斯克兰顿办一场，詹娜。哦，那简直是板上钉钉的事。
We got to go to Scranton. We got to do an Office, ladies, from Scranton. All right. It's been said. Now it must be done. Lady, tell them what we're talking about today. Today is season four, episode 17, Job Fair. This was written by Lee Eisenberg and Jean Stepnitzke, writers of dinner party, and directed
我们得去斯克兰顿。我们得在斯克兰顿办一期“办公室女士”。好吧。既然说出口了，那就必须得办。女士，告诉他们我们今天在聊什么。今天是第四季第十七集，招聘会。本剧由《晚宴》的编剧李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基编剧，由
by Tucker Gates. Would you like a summary? I can't wait for your summaries. Like Wednesday night, you know, because we record on Thursday, I go to bed and I'm like, oh, what is Jenna's summary going to be? I know you do. I know. You try to text me and get me to tell you my summary is ahead of time and I say you're
塔克·盖茨执导。你想来个剧情梗概吗？我已经迫不及待想听你的梗概了。就像周三晚上一样，你知道的，因为我们在周四录制，我上床睡觉时就会想，哦，詹娜的梗概会是什么样的呢？我知道你会这么想。我知道。你会试图发信息让我提前把梗概告诉你，而我会说你
just going to have to wait for it. Yeah. You're going to surprise me. I go to bed thinking about it. I wake up thinking about it. Well, here it is. Wait no longer. Okay.
就等着听吧。是啊。你会给我一个惊喜。我上床睡觉时在想这个。醒来时也在想这个。好吧，就是这样。不用再等了。好吧。
Michael, Pam, Oscar and Daryl attend a job fair at Pam's Alma Mater Valley View High School in search of the quote best and brightest potential summer interns. Jim is on probation at Dunder Mifflin. You know, he got his warning from Ryan. So he is going to attempt to redeem himself by working a potential client over golf with the help of Andy and Kevin. The rest of the Dunder Mifflin employees take the day off despite a warning from Dwight except for Angela who ends her silent treatment of him when they find themselves alone in
迈克尔、帕姆、奥斯卡和达里尔参加了帕姆的母校——景景高中（Valley View High School）的招聘会，寻找他们口中的“最优秀、最聪明的潜在暑期实习生”。吉姆在邓德麦弗林处于留用察看期。你知道的，他收到了瑞安的警告。所以他打算通过与安迪和凯文合作，在球场上搞定一位潜在客户来为自己赎罪。其余的邓德麦弗林员工都请假了，尽管德怀特发出了警告，但安吉拉除外，当他们在办公室里独处时，她结束了对他的冷战。
the office. It's perfect. That's a perfect summary. Thank you. You're welcome. Fast fact. Number one, Valley View High School, Pam's Alma Mater. Yeah.
太完美了。这真是一个完美的梗概。谢谢。不客气。冷知识。第一条，景景高中，帕姆的母校。是的。
We got mail. Anna R and Courtney K asked, is Valley View High School a real high school and did you film there? And? It is a real high school. Ding, ding, ding. It's about nine miles north of Scranton in the suburb of Archbold. Their school mascot is the cougar.
我们收到邮件了。安娜·R和考特尼·K问，景景高中是一所真正的学校吗？你们是在那里拍摄的吗？还有呢？它是一所真正的高中。答对了，叮叮叮。它位于斯克兰顿以北约九英里的阿奇博尔德郊区。他们的学校吉祥物是美洲狮。
And their school colors appear to be blue and yellow, maybe blue and gold. Gold is yellow. I went to the website because it's the cougar, right? So you're saying it's yellow? I'm saying it's goldy yellow. Gold is yellow. Okay. Their colors are blue and goldish yellow.
他们的校色似乎是蓝色和黄色，也许是蓝色和金色。金色就是黄色。我上了他们的网站，因为吉祥物是美洲狮，对吧？所以你是说它是黄色的？我说它是金黄色。金色就是黄色。好吧。他们的颜色是蓝色和金黄色。
Okay. We did not film at that school. Oh no. We filmed at Birmingham High School in Van Nuys, California. By the way, in my research, I discovered that the music videos for Gwen Stefani's Hollaback Girl, Eminem's No Love and Lil Wayne's Prom Queen have also all filmed at Birmingham High School. Very, very popular location.
好吧。我们并不是在那所学校拍摄的。哦，不。我们是在加州范奈斯的伯明翰高中拍摄的。顺便说一句，我在做调查时发现，格温·史蒂芬尼的《Hollaback Girl》、埃米纳姆的《No Love》和里尔·韦恩的《Prom Queen》的音乐录影带也都是在伯明翰高中拍摄的。这是一个非常非常受欢迎的取景地。
Well, wait for it, Angela. Do you know what else is filmed there? Oh God. Oh, let me guess. Let me guess. Fast Times at Ridgemont High. No. Grease.
好吧，拭目以待吧，安吉拉。你知道那里还拍过什么吗？哦，天哪。哦，让我猜猜。让我猜猜。《开放的美国学府》。不是。《油脂》。
It's an office connection. Oh. Hmm. A 40 year old virgin? An episode of Monk. What is it with the office and Monk? I don't know. I really wish we had filmed back in like the 50s.
这是一个《办公室》的彩蛋。哦。嗯。《四十岁的老处男》？《神探阿蒙》的一集。为什么《办公室》和《神探阿蒙》总有联系？我不知道。我真的很希望我们能回到50年代拍戏。
Remember when they would do those crossover episodes and all of a sudden like Laverne and Shirley would be over at, you know, the Fonzie's house? Yeah. It'd be like Happy Days, Laverne and Shirley. What if we had a Monk the office crossover? I wish we could go back in time and make that happen because we clearly use the same locations and the same guest stars. Have Tony Chaloux walk into the bullpen?
还记得他们拍那些交叉剧集的时候吗，突然之间，拉维恩和雪莉就会出现在福茨的家里？是的。就像《欢乐时光》交叉《拉维恩和雪莉》。如果我们来个《神探阿蒙》和《办公室》的交叉剧集会怎么样？我希望我们能回到过去让它发生，因为我们显然用了相同的取景地和相同的客串明星。让托尼·夏尔赫布走进办公区？
Come on. And interview someone. Maybe Toby for being the Scranton Strangler. Yes! We did it. We did it. There it is, everybody. Your office reunion is also a Monk crossover done.
拜托。然后采访某个人。也许采访托比，因为他是斯克兰顿扼喉手。太棒了！我们做到了。我们做到了。就是这样，各位。你们的《办公室》重聚也成了一次《神探阿蒙》的交叉联动，搞定。
A little more information on the school. The school colors for Birmingham High School appear to be blue and white. Kent Zabornak told me that we had to create all of our own signage and props for the school because we had to make sure, per our agreement with Birmingham High School, that none of their actual logos or artwork or signage was seen. So there you go. We made it all. Everything hanging on the wall.
关于这所学校的更多信息。伯明翰高中的校色似乎是蓝色和白色。肯·扎博纳克告诉我，我们必须为学校制作我们自己的所有标牌和道具，因为根据我们与伯明翰高中的协议，我们必须确保看不到他们任何实际的标志、艺术品或标牌。所以你看。我们把所有的东西都自己做出来了。挂在墙上的所有东西。
Everything. Wowzers. That's a lot. Listen, Kent told me that as I was watching the episode, I was like, that's a lot of signs. Yeah. Check it out. I was very busy this episode. They were.
全都是。哇塞。那可真不少。听着，肯在我看这集的时候告诉我，当时我想，这标牌也太多了吧。是啊。你看。我这一集可忙坏了。确实。
I'm moving us into fast fact number two. It's called golfing. Wait, wait. I sense a location breakdown. You are correct, Angela. And it's because we got a fan question from Sophia D. Where did you film the scenes at the golf course? Because I'll have you notice, I looked.
我要把我们带入冷知识第二条。它叫打高尔夫球。等等，等等。我感觉有一个取景地解析要来了。安吉拉，你猜对了。因为我们收到了来自索菲亚·D的粉丝提问。你们是在哪里拍摄高尔夫球场上的场景的？因为我注意到并寻找了。
We never see a sign for where our guys are supposed to be. I googled, there is a country club of Scranton that offers golf as well as a few other golf courses near the Scranton area. I don't know which course this is supposed to be, but we filmed at Vista Valencia Golf course in Santa Clarita. It's a 27 hole facility. It has an 18 hole par 61 course and a nine hole par three course. Now here's what I found very interesting, maybe only to me.
我们从来没有看到过标牌显示我们的男士们应该在哪里。我用谷歌搜索过，斯克兰顿有一家乡村俱乐部提供高尔夫服务，斯克兰顿附近还有其他几家高尔夫球场。我不知道这应该是哪个球场，但我们是在圣克拉利塔的维斯塔瓦伦西亚高尔夫球场拍摄的。这是一个27洞的设施。它有一个18洞标准杆61杆的球场和一个9洞标准杆3杆的球场。现在，这是我觉得非常有趣的地方，也许只有我觉得有趣。
Let's hear it. The prices to play depend on what day you're playing and also what time you arrive. It's least expensive to go during the week in the afternoon. If you come first thing in the morning, it's going to cost you $24.50 to walk the course or $36.50 to ride it. If you come at three o'clock, it's only $13 to walk it and $23.50 to ride it. But why is it more expensive to ride it? Is it because it comes with the cart?
说来听听。打球的价格取决于你打球的日子以及你到达的时间。工作日下午去是最便宜的。如果你一大早去，步行打球需要花24.50美元，坐球车则是36.50美元。如果你在三点钟去，步行只需要13美元，坐球车是23.50美元。但为什么坐球车更贵呢？是因为包含球车费用吗？
I couldn't find that information. It seems like you'd flow faster if you're riding it than if you're walking it. That's what everybody, I don't know a lot about golfing. I don't. This is why I'm quiet because I'm like, I don't know. But here's the big kicker and this is why I think you and I need to go to this golf course. Okay.
我找不到相关信息。看起来坐球车应该比步行移动得更快。这就是每个人，我对高尔夫了解不多。我确实不了解。这就是为什么我很安静，因为我想，我不知道。但这里有个重磅消息，这就是为什么我觉得你和我需要去这个高尔夫球场。好吧。
They have something called foot golf. Foot golf. I'd never heard of it. It's a real thing. It's a combination of soccer and golf. And hacky sack. I think you could hacky and sack it in there. There's basically a special golf course, but the holes are really big and you kick the
他们有一种叫做足式高尔夫（foot golf）的东西。足式高尔夫。我从来没听说过。这是真事。它是足球和高尔夫的结合体。还有哈基球。我觉得你可以在里面踢踢哈基球。基本上有一个特殊的高尔夫球场，但洞非常大，你把球
ball down the course into the hole. Okay. Foot golf. Maybe we could frulf and then foot golf. I would foot golf if there was like a pony keg set up on like the eighth hole. So like you kick your ball, then you have a beer, then you kick your ball. What's a pony keg? A pony keg?
沿着球场踢进洞里。好吧。也许我们可以先玩飞盘高尔夫，然后再玩足式高尔夫。如果第八洞左右设置了一个小啤酒桶的话，我会去玩足式高尔夫的。就像你把球踢出去，然后喝一杯啤酒，然后再踢球。什么是小啤酒桶？小啤酒桶？
Isn't that? Don't y'all have pony kegs? It's like a party keg. It's like a mini keg of beer. A pony keg? Anyone? Sam? Cassie?
难道不是吗？你们难道没有小啤酒桶吗？就像派对桶一样。就像一个迷你啤酒桶。小啤酒桶？有人知道吗？山姆？卡茜？
Pony keg? Ever heard of it? A pony keg is a mini keg? Yeah. It's like a baby keg. No. You're right. Pony keg is a quarter keg.
小啤酒桶？听说过吗？小啤酒桶是迷你桶吗？是的。就像一个小宝宝桶。不对。你说得对。小啤酒桶是四分之一桶。
Yeah. Thank you. What's a half keg called? Silence. I don't find any cool names. Oh. So you can get up. Here are your choices.
是的。谢谢。半个桶叫什么？一片寂静。我没发现有什么酷炫的名字。哦。所以你可以选。这就是你的选择。
Pony keg, half keg, keg. I feel like they sell more pony kegs just because the name is cute, but I don't know. And you can carry them if you're on the petite side like myself. Oh, we're learning so much today. So much. Fast fact number three, Angela, you were very, very, very pregnant in this episode. Yeah, I was. When you were filming your scenes with Dwight in the office, Lee Eisenberg had the flu.
小啤酒桶，半桶，整桶。我觉得他们卖小啤酒桶更多是因为名字很可爱，但我不知道。而且如果你像我一样身材娇小，你可以搬得动它们。哦，我们今天学到了好多。学到了太多。冷知识第三条，安吉拉，你在这一集里真的非常非常非常显怀。对，我是。当你和德怀特在办公室拍摄对手戏时，李·艾森伯格得了流感。
He was not there that day. Only Gene Stupnitsky was on the set. And they got into the editing bay to edit the episode Lee Eisenberg was there. And he said, you guys, why don't we have any wider shots of these scenes? And Dave Rogers and Gene had to remind him because Angela's belly was very hard to hide. So all of these, all of these shots are like Angela from like the shoulders up. But here is what else I found in my Googling, Angela, what by the time this episode aired, you had given birth.
那天他不在。只有吉恩·斯图普尼茨基在片场。当他们进入剪辑室剪辑李·艾森伯格在的那集时，他说，各位，为什么这些场景我们没有更多一点的广角镜头呢？戴夫·罗杰斯和吉恩不得不提醒他，因为安吉拉的肚子实在很难藏住。所以所有这些镜头，所有这些镜头基本上都是安吉拉肩膀以上的镜头。但是，安吉拉，我在谷歌上还发现了另一件事，当这一集播出时，你已经生了。
I know you gave birth five days before this episode aired. That is true. Well, lady, I have a really fun story from this episode. And it's something that involves the golf course. I had no scenes at the golf course, but I went to visit the fellas. I was doing a whole series at this time on NBC.com called Adventures with Angela. And Creed and Ed had written a song for my baby. I mean, with the banjo, the guitar, the whole thing.
我知道你在这一集播出前五天生了孩子。千真万确。好吧，女士，我有一个关于这一集的非常有趣的趣事。这跟高尔夫球场有关。我在高尔夫球场没有戏份，但我去探望了那几位男士。当时我在NBC.com上做一个名为《安吉拉大冒险》的系列节目。克里德和埃德为我的宝宝写了一首歌。我是说，有班卓琴，吉他，全套的。
So I went to the golf course on Monday, on their lunch, and we sat out in this beautiful green, like grassy area. And they sang to me. And not only that, I couldn't remember how we got there. I was like, I don't remember driving to this place or where it was. And you know, when you're a passenger, how you don't really pay attention as much, yeah. So I found this email that I had written to John Krasinski, where I said, hey, John, I'll see you Monday.
所以我周一在他们吃午饭的时候去了高尔夫球场，我们坐在草地这片美丽的绿色区域里。他们为我唱歌。不仅如此，我甚至记不清我们是怎么到那里的。我想，我不记得开车去过这个地方，也不记得它在哪里。你知道的，当你是个乘客时，你其实不会那么注意，对吧。所以我找到了我写给约翰·卡拉辛斯基的一封电子邮件，上面写着，嘿，约翰，我周一见你。
I can't wait. Creed is picking me up in his sports car. Should I be scared? And we're going to come and have lunch. And he and Ed are going to sing a song for my little baby. Oh, so you wrote in Creed's sports car? I wrote in Creed's little two-seater sports car. And they sang this song to me.
我等不及了。克里德开着他的跑车来接我。我该害怕吗？我们要去吃午饭，他和埃德要为我的小宝宝唱一首歌。哦，所以你是坐克里德的跑车去的？我是坐克里德的小型双座跑车去的。他们为我唱了这首歌。
And it was on NBC.com. And Jenna, they gave me a copy, and I tore my house up looking for this this week. I have ransacked the whole house. I know I have it somewhere, and I really wanted to play it for you guys. But Joya, who worked with us over at NBC.com, is on the case. She's going to find it. And hopefully, maybe in a revisited, I'll be able to play it for you guys, because it's really special.
这首歌被发在了NBC.com上。詹娜，他们给了我一份拷贝，这周我把家里翻了个底朝天找它。我把整个房子都搜了个遍。我知道我把它放在某个地方，我真的很想放给你们听。但是乔亚，曾在NBC.com和我们共事过的人，正在跟进这件事。她会找到它的。希望在某期重温节目中，我能把它放给你们听，因为它真的很特别。
And I'm just heartbroken that I couldn't find it. That is so cool, Angela. I remember seeing the video of that, so I really do hope you find it. Me too. Me too. It was so cute. I remember Creed started off with Angela's baby. It was just so fun.
而且我找不到它，心里真的很难过。太酷了，安吉拉，我记得看过那个视频，所以我真的希望你能找到它。我也是。我也是。太可爱了。我还记得克里德是以“安吉拉的宝宝”开头的。真的太有趣了。
Well, and that's really all I had for this. I guess I have something that could be considered half a fast fact that I could throw in there. Half a fast fact? What you got? My half a fast fact is that Toby was not in this episode because he was busy writing the season finale. Oh, that is a good one. Well, I have a little Kinsey tidbit.
好吧，关于这个我其实就这么多了。我想我有一个可以算作半个冷知识的事可以塞进来。半个冷知识？你有什么货？我的半个冷知识是，托比这一集没有出场，因为他正忙着写季终集。哦，这个料不错。好吧，我还有一个金西的小八卦。
Oh, guess who found her script of job fair? This lady. Oh my gosh, Angela, this is very exciting to me because I have a couple of fan questions that I didn't know the answer to, but I bet the answers are in the script. Oh, let me get it. I'll get it. And let's go to break and we'll come back and jump into some job fair. I like it.
哦，猜猜谁找到了她的《招聘会》剧本？就是本人。哦天哪，安吉拉，这对我很兴奋，因为我有几个粉丝提问我不知道答案，但我敢肯定答案就在剧本里。哦，我去拿。我去拿。我们去休息一下，然后回来继续聊《招聘会》。我喜欢。
All right, we are back. I have my script of job fair and Jenna right out of the gate. I have a question for you. What is it? Did you notice that this episode does not have a cold open? I kind of did, Angela. We have a scene before the credits, but it's on plot. It's on story.
好了，我们回来了。我拿到了我的《招聘会》剧本，詹娜，一开场。我有个问题要问你。什么问题？你有没有注意到这一集没有冷开场？我好像注意到了，安吉拉。我们在片头字幕前有一个场景，但它跟剧情有关。它跟故事有关。
It's not one of those standalone comedic cold opens that we're used to. I did notice. That's right. We just kind of get right into the meat of the episode, right? Yes. There was a cold open and I'm going to read you a little bit about what it was. Okay. Okay.
它不是那种我们习惯的独立的喜剧式冷开场。我注意到了。没错。我们算是直接切入正题了，对吧？是的。其实本来有一个冷开场，我要给你们读一点关于它的内容。好吧。好吧。
So in the cold open, you hear the screaming noise from the men's restroom and everyone in the bullpen kind of grumbles like, ah, not again. And Michael comes out. He's just exasperated because he has dropped everything that was in his pockets into the toilet, like everything. He lists it off. He dropped his cell phone, his tip calculator, his wallet, his white strips, candy corn, his eraser, and then Jim says, what about your car keys?
所以在这个冷开场里，你听到男厕所里传来尖叫声，办公区的每个人都抱怨说，啊，又来了。然后迈克尔出来了。他简直气急败坏，因为他把他口袋里的所有东西都掉进马桶里了，就像所有东西一样。他数了数。他掉了手机、小费计算器、钱包、美白牙贴、玉米糖、橡皮擦，然后吉姆说，你的车钥匙呢？
And Michael says, I threw them into the toilet out of anger. And this leads him to this light bulb moment because I guess this happens quite frequently for Michael and he goes into his office and he comes out and he's like, guys, I have invented this amazing invention and he says it's the mesh toilet guard to go over the toilet. And then the camera pans passed him and he has just cut out the back of his desk chair that's mesh into like a circle and he's like, who's going to volunteer? This is going to be great. It's lightweight, portable, reusable.
迈克尔说，我气急败坏把它们扔进马桶里了。这让他灵光一现，因为我想这对迈克尔来说经常发生，他走进办公室，然后出来说，伙计们，我发明了一个惊人的发明，他说这是一个网状马桶防护罩，可以盖在马桶上。然后镜头扫过他，他刚刚把他办公椅背上的网布剪成了一个圆圈，他说，谁来志愿当小白鼠？这太棒了。它很轻，便携，可重复使用。
You can just put it in your dishwasher. So what he's going to start using the bathroom through this meshy cover, but he's thrilled. He thinks he's going to be a gazillionaire with the mesh toilet guard. I don't know where to begin. I know. So that was the cold open that they didn't end up using and they just jumped right into the episode. Here's the thing.
你甚至可以直接把它放进洗碗机。所以他要开始通过这个网状盖子使用洗手间了，但他兴奋极了。他觉得有了这个网状马桶防护罩，他就要成亿万富翁了。我不知道该从哪里吐槽。我知道。所以这就是他们最终没用、直接跳进剧集的冷开场。事情是这样的。
I can't remember if we shot that, but I remember that joke probably from the table read because we must have read it. I remember the joke that Michael threw his keys in out of anger. That was my favorite part. So this isn't in the deleted scenes then. It's not in the deleted scenes, but it is in the script, but they didn't use it. It's a little trivia for you since I have the script. The script is paying off already.
我记不清我们当时有没有拍那个场景，但我记得这个笑话，大概是通过剧本围读，因为我们一定读过。我记得迈克尔气急败坏把钥匙扔进去的那个笑话。那是我的最爱。所以这不是删减片段喽。这不在删减片段里，但它在剧本里，只是他们没用。既然我有剧本，这就当是给你们的一点冷门小知识吧。剧本现在就已经开始起作用了。
I'm excited about it. The way this episode does start is Michael comes out of his office. He's dressed in his jeans. Yeah. It's got sneakers on. He's trying to look young and hip. I think so. Pam and Oscar and Daryl are all around reception and we find out that today the four of them
我很激动。这一集的开头是迈克尔从办公室走出来。他穿着牛仔裤。是的。还穿着运动鞋。他试图让自己看起来年轻又时髦。我觉得是。帕姆、奥斯卡和达里尔都在前台周围，我们发现今天他们四个人
will be attending the job fair at Valley View High School in search of new interns because he wants to euthanize the office. Well, there is a deleted scene where Michael shares that he's been really depressed since Ryan left. Sam, can you play that? I am depressed, but since Ryan left, I've been going through empty nest syndrome and I call it that because that's the way I felt when empty nest went off the air. I am lonely and I need a new Ryan.
将前往景景高中参加招聘会，寻找新的实习生，因为他想给办公室注入活力。好吧，有一个删减片段，迈克尔在其中分享说，自从瑞安离开后，他一直很沮丧。山姆，你能放一下那个吗？我很沮丧，但自从瑞安离开后，我一直在经历空巢综合症，我这么叫是因为当《空巢》停播时我就是这种感觉。我很孤独，我需要一个新的瑞安。
That's amazing. Yeah. And so he sees this job fair at the local high school as his way to recruit some young buddy. Michael just wants a younger sibling. Yeah. We had a fan question from Thomas V. How did they decide who got to go to the job fair? This was one of those instances where they would look at the cast and they would say,
太绝了。是的。所以他把当地高中的这场招聘会看作是招募年轻死党的方式。迈克尔只是想要一个弟弟或妹妹。是的。我们收到了托马斯·V的一个粉丝提问。他们是怎么决定谁去招聘会的？这是他们会看看演员阵容并说，
who haven't we seen together yet or in a while? And that's kind of how they hold the names because something I noticed is that there is not technically a salesperson represented. So there's someone from accounting, there's someone from the warehouse, front reception who Michael refers to as the eye candy. And Michael, who I guess could also cover sales. Right. He was a really good salesman.
我们还没把谁组合在一起过，或者好久没在一起了？这就是他们挑选名单的方式，因为我注意到的一点是，这里技术上没有代表销售人员的人。所以有来自会计部门的人，有来自仓库的人，还有前台，迈克尔称之为养眼担当。还有迈克尔，我想他也可以兼顾销售。没错。他是个非常棒的销售员。
He was. Yeah. And this was more about pairing of people and characters and who would make a great foil for Michael at the job fair. Well we know why I couldn't go. Yeah. You would have just to shoot four floating heads. It would have just been four heads in a high school auditorium because that was super
他确实是。是的。这更多是关于人和角色的配对，以及谁能在招聘会上成为迈克尔的绝佳衬托。好吧，我们知道为什么我不能去。是的。你去了就只能拍四个漂浮的头了。那就只剩高中礼堂里的四颗脑袋了，因为那是超级
pranks. Okay. So that's who went to the high school. But now we have this other kind of odd pairing headed to the golf course. It's Jim Andy and Kevin and Jim's on probation. He's got to make this big, big sale. And this is his ragtag team that I guess is going to help him. Yeah.
恶作剧。好吧，这就是去高中人选。但现在我们有另一对奇怪的组合正前往高尔夫球场。是吉姆、安迪和凯文，而且吉姆处于留用察看期。他必须拿下这笔超级大单。而这群乌合之众就是他选来帮忙的吧。是的。
Things start off a little, how would you put it? Oddly because the first thing that Andy does is insult Mr. McGuire, their potential client because he's wearing a Dartmouth sweatshirt. He tells him to take it off and that his grandfather would be spinning in his urn if he knew he was golfing with a Dartmouth alum. There's clearly some real rivalry here between Cornell and Dartmouth. Well I looked it up. It's this big college football rivalry between the Cornell Big Red and the Dartmouth Big
事情开始得有点，你会怎么形容？有点古怪，因为安迪做的第一件事就是侮辱了他们的潜在客户麦奎尔先生，因为他穿着一件达特茅斯大学的卫衣。他让他把衣服脱掉，并说如果他知道自己在和一个达特茅斯校友打高尔夫，他爷爷在骨灰盒里都会气得直打转。康奈尔大学和达特茅斯大学之间显然存在着真正的竞争关系。好吧，我查了一下。这是康奈尔大红队和达特茅斯大绿队之间的一场盛大的大学橄榄球宿敌之战。
Green. I guess these two schools were major football powers back in the day. There's since been a split in the divisions, the football divisions, but prior to the split, Cornell kind of dominated the national championships. They won in 1915, 1921, 22, 23, and 39 Dartmouth won once in 1925. So Cornell was dominating the Ivy League. Yes. But then in 1940, there was this infamous game, Amj.
我猜这两所学校在当年都是橄榄球劲旅。自那以后，联盟进行了拆分，橄榄球联盟进行了拆分，但在拆分之前，康奈尔曾在一定程度上统治了全国锦标赛。他们在1915、1921、22、23和39年赢得过冠军，达特茅斯在1925年赢过一次。所以康奈尔曾统治常春藤盟校。是的。但在1940年，发生了一场声名狼藉的比赛，AMJ。
Oh. Cornell had a 16 game winning streak. And this was like a school record. They were about to win the national championship with a score of seven to three, but guess what they did? What? They did a film review of the game and found out that Cornell had inadvertently used five downs instead of four, and they had to forfeit the game to Dartmouth.
哦。康奈尔当时取得了16连胜。这就像是一个校纪录。他们本可以以7比3的比分赢得全国锦标赛，但你猜他们做了什么？什么？他们对比赛进行了录像回放，发现康奈尔无意中用了五次进攻机会而不是四次，他们不得不将比赛判负给达特茅斯。
Oh. According to the ESPN College Football Encyclopedia, they consider this to be the second greatest moment in college football history, and it is commonly referred to as the fifth down game. So I guess that's why Andy's grandfather was spinning in his urn. Well, Mindy went to Dartmouth, so she might have known some of that rivalry. I have to think that might have come up in the writer's room. I wonder.
哦。根据《ESPN大学橄榄球百科全书》，他们认为这是大学橄榄球史上第二伟大的时刻，它通常被称为“第五档比赛”。我想这就是为什么安迪的爷爷在骨灰盒里直打转了。好吧，明迪上的是达特茅斯，所以她可能知道一些这种宿敌之争。我猜编剧室里可能提到过这个。我想是的。
And there are deleted scenes that support this. Jim shares that, you know what? He's bringing Andy on purpose because he knew Andy would flip out about Mr. McGuire being a Dartmouth guy, and then they would have sort of this like common enemy that it would be bonding for Mr. McGuire and Jim because Andy's an idiot. Well, that doesn't track because Jim seems so horrified by Andy's comment to Mr. McGuire. Exactly. So then there's the scene where, you know, Mr. McGuire's like, gosh, this guy and Jim's
而且有删减片段支持这一点。吉姆分享说，你知道吗？他故意带上安迪，因为他知道安迪一听到麦奎尔先生是达特茅斯的人就会抓狂，然后他们就会有某种共同的敌人，这会让麦奎尔先生和吉姆之间产生凝聚力，因为安迪是个白痴。好吧，这说不通，因为吉姆看起来对安迪对麦奎尔先生的评论感到非常震惊。没错。所以接下来有这样一个场景，你知道的，麦奎尔先生说，天哪，这家伙，然后吉姆说，我懂，康奈尔，对吧？哦，我明白了。哦，是的。
like, I know, Cornell, right? Oh, I get it. Oh, yeah. Jim was being diabolical. He had a whole plan. Right. Best friends through a common enemy. That's right.
吉姆太腹黑了。他有个全盘计划。通过共同的敌人结为挚友。没毛病。看看我们。我们现在是哥们儿了。我们是好朋友。把你的业务交给我。别理那个康奈尔白痴。感谢上帝你身边有我。是的。
Look at us. We're buddies now. We're pals. Give me your business. Don't pay attention to that Cornell idiot. Thank God you have me here. Yeah. Don't pay attention to that idiot who also works at my company.
别理那个也在我们公司上班的白痴。我不知道这算不算是个好计划，吉姆。好吧，这是他策略的一部分。安迪甚至不能和麦奎尔先生握手，因为他的手上全是水泡。水泡泡。是的。他是新奇礼物达人。他长水泡泡了。他特别喜欢在词尾加“ie”。
I don't know if this was a great plan, Jim. Well, part of his strategy. Andy also can't shake hands with Mr. McGuire because his hands are covered in blisters. Blisties. Yeah. He's nifty gifties. He's blisties. He loves a little IES on things.
我打听到了那些水泡是怎么做出来的内幕。哦，说来听听。是谁弄的？是我们的化妆师拉韦恩。她画的妆。她花了大约20到30分钟才搞定。她先在手上涂上颜色，所以她有点把手涂成了红色。然后她用一种叫做RCMA造疤材料的东西覆盖。
I got the lowdown on how they made those blisters. Oh, let's hear it. Who did it? It was our makeup artist Laverne. She applied the makeup. It took her about 20 or 30 minutes to do it. She started by putting coloring on his hands, so she kind of painted his hands red. Then she covered it with something called RCMA scar making material.
她说这东西非常非常难涂，因为一旦干了，就定型了。你没法移动它，而且干得非常非常快。所以她会用一个小金属刮刀和镊子快速地把它涂上，事后埃德不准洗手，也不能弄湿手。那你怎么上厕所？我是说，我猜他只是事后不洗手。希望他在其他任何方面都没有把手弄湿。你每次上完厕所都会洗手吗？
She said it's really, really tricky to apply because as soon as it dries, it's set. You can't move it and it dries really, really fast. So she would put it on really quickly with a tiny metal spatula and tweezers and that afterwards Ed was not allowed to wash his hands or get them wet. How do you go to the bathroom? I mean, I guess he just didn't wash his hands after. I hope he didn't awkward get them wet in any other way. Do you always wash your hands after you go to the bathroom?
是的。在家里也洗？是的。你在家里嘘嘘完之后，每次都会用肥皂和水洗手吗？每次都洗。每次我都会冲洗，我有一个按压式的洗手液瓶。或者我有一块大香皂，每次我都会用手在香皂上搓。我妈从小就给我灌输这个习惯。
Yes. Even at home? Yes. After you pee at home, you wash your hands with soap and water every time? Every time. Every time I rinse them and I have a little pump, pump. Or I have a big bar and I rub my hand over the bar soap every time. It was drilled into me by my mom.
我每次都会冲洗双手，我还会让伊莎贝拉也这样。所以这就像是本能。我觉得现在很清楚了，我并不总是像你那样在家里嘘嘘完后洗手。我觉得也许我们本可以因为某些事情产生共鸣，但现在我们没法产生共鸣了。哦，不。现在我只觉得你很恶心。我想你现在来我家时得提心吊胆了。我嘘嘘完洗手了吗？
I rinse my hands every time and I make Isabelle. So it's just like automatic. I feel like it's really clear now that I don't always wash my hands after I pee at home. I feel like maybe we were going to bond over something but now we're not bonding over. Oh no. And now I just think you're disgusting. I guess now you're going to have to worry when you come over to my house. Did I wash my hands after I pee?
我便便完总是洗手，总是。我从来没有擦完便便不洗手的，各位。好吧，很好。我觉得我想把这一点说清楚。好吧，我才不担心呢。我只是不碰你的手，也不碰你手碰过的任何东西。我不知道该怎么看待这段对话。好吧，我们大概应该把话题岔开了。
I always wash my hands after poop, always. I never wipe a poop and then not wash my hands everybody. Well good. I feel like I want that to be clear. Well, I'm not going to worry. I'm just not going to touch your hands or anything your hands touch. I don't know how I feel about this conversation. Well, we should probably segue out of it.
好吧，关于水泡我只想说这些。这可能属于你已经知道的事情的范畴，但作为“办公室女士”初出茅庐的业余医学专家，你永远不应该挑破水泡。水泡里面的液体有愈合特性，它还能保护受影响的区域，这样你就不会感染。所以你真的希望液体在里面呆尽可能长的时间，让水泡自己愈合。不要挑破它。
Well, I'll say this about blisters. It might fall under the heading of things you already know, but as the emerging amateur medical expert of office ladies, you should never pop a blister. The fluid inside your blister has healing properties and it also protects the affected areas so that you won't get an infection. So you really want the fluid to stay in there as long as possible and just let the blister heal itself. Don't pop it.
我以前不知道这一点。我觉得我挑破过好多水泡。这太有趣了。我以后再也不挑水泡了。我只会看着它，然后对自己说，詹娜告诉我让它顺其自然。所以我打算让它顺其自然。我可能以后在家里嘘嘘完也会开始洗手了。希望如此。
I did not know that. I feel like I have popped many a blister. This is so interesting. I'm not going to pop a blister now. I'm just going to look at it and say Jenna told me to let it do its thing. So I'm going to let it do its thing. I might start washing my hands after I pee at home. I hope so.
现在麦奎尔先生想让这场高尔夫比赛变得更有趣。所以他建议他们下点小赌注。为什么不赌一小把呢？哦，天哪。这简直是正中凯文下怀。凯文心想，什么，什么？麦奎尔先生建议每洞10美元。但凯文，詹娜，他列举了所有这些游戏。
Well now Mr. McGuire wants to make this golf game more interesting. So he suggests that they make a little wager. Why don't they do a little betting? Oh my gosh. This is music to Kevin's ears. Kevin's like, what, what? Mr. McGuire suggests $10 a whole. But Kevin, Jenna, he lists all of these games.
我知道。我都记下来了。你想听听都有什么吗？我想听。好吧。他说，你想打Skins、AC Ducey、Bingo Bango Bongo、Sandys、Barky's、Wolf、Arnie's吗？别忘了Arnie's。
I know. I wrote them down. You want to hear what they are? I do. All right. He says, you want to play skins, A.C. Ducey, Bingo Bango Bongo, Sandys, Barky's, Wolfe, Arnie's. Don't forget Arnie's.
哦，真的很抱歉。我忘了Arnie's。我查过了。这些全都是打高尔夫球时真正的下注方式。都是真的。我的意思是，我能对所有这些进行解释。我就不展开讲了，但太迷人了。我甚至不知道打高尔夫球能有这么多赌法。
Oh, I'm so sorry. I forgot Arnie's. I looked it up. These are all real ways to bet on golf. They're real. I mean, I have an explanation for all of them. I won't go into it, but fascinating. I didn't even realize you could do this much golf betting.
很显然，高尔夫赌博有这么多。你知道吗？凯文知道这一点很符合人设。是的。这勾起了他骨子里的赌徒心理。而且他承认他要拿走奥斯卡的零用钱，用来支付下个月的房租。所以他是在用邓德麦弗林的零用钱赌博。
Clearly, there's so much golf gambling. And you know what? It tracks that Kevin would know. Yeah. This is bringing up his whole gambling thing. And he admits that he's going to take the petty cash from Oscar and use it to turn it into next month's rent. So he is gambling with Dundermifflin's petty cash.
我们该进入这个招聘会了吗，女士？好的。让我们进入招聘会。帕姆不得不回忆起她高中的青葱岁月，你从中了解了她很多事情。是的。她有一个单人访谈，说这个体育馆让她想起她所有假装痛经以逃避体育课的时光。特别是排球，然而在公司野餐时，她却像个排球高手。
Should we move on to this job fair, lady? Yes. Let's move on to the job fair. Pam has to walk down memory lane of her high school, and you learn a lot about her. Yeah. She has this talking head where she says this gym reminds her of all the time she pretended to have PMS to get out of playing sports. In particular, volleyball, but yet in company picnics, she's like a volleyball pro.
所以这是怎么回事？哦，我们收到过比这更多的邮件吗？我感觉被理解了。谢谢每一位写信的朋友，帕姆一说这话，我就想，搞什么鬼？我知道切尔西·B写信提出了一个理论，解释为什么她一边假装痛经一边还能是排球冠军这依然说得通。我很喜欢。所以切尔西的理论是这样的。
So what's happening? Oh, have we ever gotten more mail? I feel seen. Thank you for everyone that wrote in as soon as Pam said that, I was like, what the heck? I know Chelsea B wrote in this theory on why it still tracks that she would have pretended to have PMS while also being a volleyball champion. And I loved it. So here is Chelsea's theory.
她说，人们总是指出一个连贯性错误，即帕姆说她假装肚子痛是为了不用在体育课上打排球。然而，也许帕姆假装肚子痛是因为她不想和那些排球打得不怎么样的同班同学一起打排球。作为一个前运动员，我可以告诉你，和一群排球很烂的人一起打我的运动，我可一点也高兴不起来。所以在看来，她试图逃避这一点并不奇怪。好吧，切尔西，我觉得你太善良了。
She says, people always point out the continuity era that Pam says she faked cramps so she wouldn't have to play volleyball in gym class. However, maybe Pam faked cramps because she didn't want to have to play volleyball with her classmates who weren't very good at it. As a former athlete myself, I can tell you I wouldn't have had much fun playing my sport with people who sucked at it. So in my opinion, it's not surprising that she'd try to get out of it. Well, Chelsea, I think you're being very kind.
什么？我很喜欢切尔西这种说法：帕姆是个如此牛逼的排球高手，以至于她根本无法忍受高中体育课的排球赛。拜托，在高中里，像她这样的人早就会被挑出来加入校队排球了。你会和那些菜鸟分开的。不，这是体育课。这就像体育课上每个人都要锻炼身体。
What? I love that Chelsea is like, Pam is such a badass volleyball player that she cannot handle a gym class volleyball game. I mean, come on in high school, like they would have pulled you out and put you in varsity volleyball. You would have been separated from the LAMOs. No, this was gym class. This was just like everybody get exercise in gym class.
我们今天要打排球。所以帕姆可能已经在校队了，但她就是不想在体育课上打。这对她的时间和天赋来说是一种浪费。好吧，切尔西。好吧。好吧。好吧。
We're going to play volleyball today. So Pam was probably on the varsity team, but she just didn't want to have to play in gym class. It was a waste of her time and talent. Okay, Chelsea. Okay. Okay. Okay.
好吧，切尔西，我太喜欢你的来信了。我很感激。切尔西，你让她今天心情大好。好吧，帕姆在穿过高中时还有一个删减片段。她走过运动奖杯陈列柜，那里有一张罗伊·安德森的大幅旧照片，他是高中的大运动健将，她看着照片说，我生命中的九年。我还记得拍那个场景的时候。他们把大卫·丹曼的照片P到了一张高中合影里。
Well, I'm living for your piece of mail, Chelsea. I appreciated it. You made her day, Chelsea. Well, there's another deleted scene with Pam as she's going through the high school. She walks past the sports trophy case and there is a big old photo of Roy Anderson, the big jock in high school, and she looks at it and says, nine years of my life. I remember shooting that. They had done this little photo shop of David Denman in a high school photo.
奥斯卡有一个被删掉的单人访谈，他说，不，出乎意料的是，我并没有一直梦想成为邓德麦弗林的一名会计。在高中时，我只是个普通孩子。我成绩还不错，在新浪潮乐队里弹贝斯，床头贴着金·贝辛格的海报。哦，我当时多么想成为金·贝辛格啊。那真是一个很棒的单人访谈。确实。
And Oscar has a deleted talking head where he says, no, surprisingly enough, I did not always dream of being an accountant at Dunder Mifflin. In high school, I was just a normal kid. I made decent grades, played bass in a new wave band, had a poster of Kim Bassenger over my bed. Oh, how I wanted to be Kim Bassenger. That is a great talking head. It was.
我真希望它能保留下来。迈克尔对自己的展位感到非常自信。自信到他唯一带来的东西就是一张白纸。所以他们四个人坐在桌子旁，面前摆着一张白纸。好吧，他说一张白纸等于无限可能。这是概念艺术。他是这么说的。与此同时，隔壁展位有一个篮球架，还有一个爆米花
I wish it had stayed in. Michael is feeling pretty confident about his booth. So much so that the only thing that he brought was a blank piece of paper. So it's the four of them sitting at a table with a blank piece of paper in front of them. Well, he says a blank sheet of paper equals endless possibilities. It's conceptual. That's what he says. Meanwhile, the booth next door has like a basketball hoop and then one has like a popcorn
机。没有人会在这个展位停留，有一个删减片段持续了很长时间。我太喜欢了，就是源源不断的小孩从你们身边走过，完全不停留，唯一一个短暂停留的人放下他的爆米花桶，直接把它当成垃圾扔在那里。爆米花洒了出来，然后奥斯卡就在那里帮这个小孩收拾垃圾。安吉拉，我们拍这些场景时太开心了。
machine. No one is going to stop by this booth and there's a deleted scene that goes on for so long. I loved it so much of just a steady stream of kids walking past you guys, not stopping at all, and the only one that stops briefly sets down his popcorn container and just leaves it there like trash. It spills over and then Oscar is just tidying up this kid's trash. Angela, we had so much fun shooting these scenes.
我太喜欢和这三位男士一起去外景了。我们度过了最美好的时光。他们给所有的背景演员导演指令，让他们在其他所有展位都玩得很开心、面带微笑且充满活力，这样当你走到我们展位时，就会显得格外安静和凄凉。这真的太管用了。当时快把我笑死了。我们要不要回邓德麦弗林看看其他人都在干什么？
I so loved getting to be on location with these three guys. We had the best time. They gave all the background actors the direction that they should be like having a great time and smiling and high energy at all the other booths so that when you got to ours, it was particularly quiet and sad looking. It really, really works. It was cracking me up. Should we go back over to Dunder Mithlin and see what everyone else is up to?
能和这三位男士一起在现场拍摄，我真的太喜欢了。我们度过了最棒的时光。他们给所有的背景演员下了指令，让他们在其他所有摊位前都表现得开开心心、满脸笑容、充满活力，这样当镜头转到我们这里时，就会显得格外安静和凄凉。这真的、真的很管用。我都快笑死了。我们要不要回邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）看看其他人都在忙什么？
Yes. Well, let me tell you what they're up to. They're up to trying to sneak out of work. I mean, Meredith and Phyllis are stirring the pot. Michael is gone. They don't want to stay the whole day. No. And Creed has a great line where he says he finished his work months ago.
是的。好吧，让我告诉你他们在干什么。他们正忙着溜出公司。我是说，梅雷迪思和菲利斯在煽风点火。迈克尔不在。他们不想待上一整天。不。克里德有一句很棒的台词，他说他几个月前就把工作做完了。
I loved that. Like, what is he doing? Dwight reminds them all that when Michael is gone, Jim is in charge. And when Jim is gone, Andy and Dwight are in charge. And when Andy is gone, you answer to Dwight. And Stanley's like, I don't give a crap. I'm out. I love so much that moment when Stanley walks out the door.
我太喜欢那句了。就像，他在干什么？德怀特提醒大家，当迈克尔不在时，吉姆负责。当吉姆不在时，安迪和德怀特负责。当安迪不在时，你们得听德怀特的。而斯坦利说，我才不在乎呢。我走人。我太喜欢斯坦利夺门而出的那个瞬间了。
I did too. And Dwight doesn't know what to do. You know, we have said we feel like Stanley is the person Dwight is like, I am not going to mess with Stanley. But Dwight asserts to the whole office, look, you guys. The American workday ends at five o'clock. And so you must stay until the end of the workday, period. Or I'll tattle on you.
我也很喜欢。而且德怀特不知道该怎么办。你知道的，我们说过我们觉得斯坦利就是那种让德怀特觉得“我绝对不要去招惹斯坦利”的人。但德怀特向整个办公室断言，听着，伙计们。美国的工作日到五点钟结束。所以你们必须待到工作日结束，听明白了吗。否则我就去打小报告。
Right. Back at the high school, Pam is chatting up a young perspective intern. He's actually interested in Dunder Mifflin. And Michael signals her to stop. Yeah. Well, not just that. He goes up to this kid whose name is Justin. He says, I don't think this is the job for you.
没错。回到高中，帕姆正在和一个年轻的潜在实习生聊天。他对邓德麦弗林很感兴趣。迈克尔示意她停下。是的。不仅如此。他走到这个叫贾斯廷的孩子面前。他说，我觉得这份工作不适合你。
Never should be more of a hobby for you. And then he takes away the kid's pamphlet that he was looking at. Yeah. We had a fan catch about it, though, from Harmjen V and Alyssa C. If Michael only brought one sheet of paper to the job fair, where did the brochure come from that Pam gave to Justin and Michael took away? Hmm. Good question.
它更应该只是你的一个业余爱好。然后他拿走了这孩子正在看的宣传册。是的。不过我们收到了一条粉丝抓帮，来自哈姆詹·V和阿莉莎·C。如果迈克尔只带了一张纸去招聘会，那帕姆给贾斯廷、后来又被迈克尔拿走的宣传册是从哪来的？嗯。好问题。
I mean, clearly they brought a brochure. I felt like the paper was their prop, was the thing that was supposed to be the eye-catching moment as people walked by. So maybe under the desk, Pam had some additional materials. When the paper makes you stop in your tracks to talk to these people at their booth, then you get a pamphlet. Okay. I like it.
我是说，很显然他们带了宣传册。我觉得那张纸是他们的道具，是当人们走过时应该起到吸引眼球作用的东西。所以也许在桌子底下，帕姆还有一些额外的材料。当这张纸吸引你停下脚步和他们展位的人交谈时，你就会拿到一本宣传册。好吧。我喜欢。
Michael is furious that Justin signed his name on their blank piece of paper. He's even more furious to learn that Pam only brought the one. Yeah. And Pam's like, excuse me? I love that she totally calls him out on it. I know. She said, Michael, do you not remember? I said, are you sure that we only need one sheet of paper?
迈克尔对贾斯廷在他们的白纸上签名感到非常愤怒。当得知帕姆只带了一张纸时，他更加愤怒了。是的。帕姆说，不好意思？我喜欢她毫不留情地当面质问他。我知道。她说，迈克尔，你难道不记得了吗？我说，你确定我们只需要一张纸吗？
And you said, yeah, we only need one sheet of paper to make a difference. And then you sneezed in my tea and said, don't worry, it's just allergies. Pam with the receipts. That's what the kids say, Jenna. Oh, I like it. We had a fan question from Kate B. When Justin signs his name on the piece of paper, he writes Justin E. But later in the episode, he tells Michael that his last name is Paul Snick. Explain.
你说，对，我们只需要一张纸就能创造不同。然后你在我的茶里打了个喷嚏，说，别担心，只是过敏而已。帕姆带着实锤来了。孩子们都这么说，詹娜。哦，我喜欢。我们收到了凯特·B的一个粉丝提问。当贾斯廷在纸上签名时，他写的是贾斯廷·E。但后来在剧中，他告诉迈克尔他的姓是保罗·斯尼克。解释一下。
I'll tell you, I am intrigued. The actor who plays Justin, his name is Trevor Einhorn. Oh, so maybe he was writing his actual last name. Yes. Isn't that amazing? So Trevor Einhorn has been a professional actor since he was five years old and his breakout role was on the television comedy, Frasier. He played Frederick Crane, the son of Frasier and Lilith.
我来告诉你，我很感兴趣。扮演贾斯廷的演员，他的名字叫特雷弗·伊恩霍恩。哦，所以他可能写的是他真实的姓氏。是的。是不是很神奇？所以特雷弗·伊恩霍恩从五岁起就是一名专业演员，他的成名作是电视喜剧《欢乐一家亲》。他饰演了弗雷泽和莉莉丝的儿子弗雷德里克·克雷恩。
Oh my gosh, yes. He also went on to have a recurring role on Mad Men. He was in season six and seven as a copywriter. And he also played Neil Kellerman in the ABC remake of Dirty Dancing. He currently stars as Josh Hoberman in the sci-fi show The Magicians. He is a Scorpio. I'll have you know. That's new for a guest.
哦天哪，没错。他后来还在《广告狂人》中获得了一个常驻角色。他在第六季和第七季中饰演一名广告文案。他还在ABC重拍版的《辣身舞》中饰演了尼尔·凯勒曼。他目前在科幻剧《魔法师》中饰演乔什·霍伯曼。他是个天蝎座。顺便告诉你们。这可是客串演员的新情报。
I don't feel like you've shared their zodiac sign before. Is this a new part of the guest star breakdown? Well, it showed up in his bio, so I thought I'd throw it in there. Okay. Finally, he is not related to our cinematographer, Randall Einhorn. That is correct. Just a coincidence. Everyone back in the bullpen still really wants to sneak out.
我感觉你以前没有分享过他们的星座。这是嘉宾演员分析的新内容吗？好吧，它出现在他的简历里，所以我想把它加进去。好吧。最后，他与我们的摄影指导兰德尔·英霍恩没有亲戚关系。没错。这只是个巧合。办公区里的每个人其实都还想偷偷溜走。
They've waited for their moment. Dwight finally gets up and exits the bullpen to go to the bathroom. And Creed calls Angela to tell her they're all leaving. This scene made me laugh so hard, Jenna, because this is a bit that Creed and I still do. To this day, Creed will text me, Pumpkin's out. Or if we hang out and I'm like, all right, Creed, I'm going to go. He'll say, Pumpkin's out, like he still says this to me after all of these years. And this just warmed my heart.
他们一直在等待时机。德怀特终于起身离开办公区去上厕所。然后柯里给安吉拉打电话，告诉她他们都要走了。这一幕让我笑得肚子疼，珍娜，因为这是我和柯里现在还会玩的一个梗。直到今天，柯里还会发短信给我，南瓜出去了。或者如果我们一起玩，我说，好了，柯里，我要走了。他会说，南瓜出去了，就像这么多年后他依然对我说这句话一样。这真的暖到了我的心。
I loved it so much. Sam, can you play the clip? One, two, eight. Hiya, Pumpkin. It's Creed. Say we're going to ditch this bitch. You in? No.
我太喜欢了。萨姆，你能播一下这段剪辑吗？一，二，八。嗨，南瓜。我是柯里。咱们说好要甩掉这个碧池。加入吗？不。
Are you out? Pumpkin's out. Let's go, gang. We got so much mail about this scene, Angela. People who listen to the podcast know that Creed calls you Pumpkin in real life. And they wanted to know, was Creed ad-libbing in the scene and using his real life nickname for you or was Pumpkin in the script and then he started calling you Pumpkin after this? This scene is exactly as it is in the script, exactly.
你出去了吗？南瓜出去了。我们走吧，伙计们。我们收到了很多关于这一幕的邮件，安吉拉。听播客的人都知道柯里在现实生活中叫你南瓜。他们想知道，柯里在这一幕里是即兴发挥用了他在现实生活中对你的昵称，还是剧本里本来就有南瓜，然后他才开始叫你南瓜的？这一幕完全是剧本里写的那样，一模一样。
So Creed did not improvise that, but I will tell you, ever since we shot Job Bear, he has called me Pumpkin to this day. He still calls me Pumpkin. That is so cute. I know. It's so cute. I loved that scene. Well now Dwight comes out of the restroom and he sees that everyone has left.
所以柯里并不是即兴发挥的，但我得告诉你，自从我们拍摄招聘会以来，他一直叫我南瓜，直到今天。他还是叫我南瓜。这太可爱了。我知道。太可爱了。我很喜欢那一幕。现在德怀特从洗手间出来，发现大家都走了。
Everyone except Angela, which makes total sense because she's the one other rule follower in this group. There is a great scene that's deleted where Dwight comes out and he goes, huh, last man standing and then Angela briskly walks past him and goes, excuse me. And then there's a talking head that Angela has that really explains why she is just as eager to be one of the last people in the office. Whenever I'm here by myself, I like to pretend that all the others are dead. So this is nice.
除了安吉拉，这完全合情合理，因为她是这个群体中另一个遵守规则的人。有一个很棒的被删减片段，讲的是德怀特出来后说，哈，最后一个站着的人，然后安吉拉轻快地从他身边走过说，不好意思。然后安吉拉有一个访谈镜头，真正解释了她为什么同样渴望成为办公室里最后留下来的人之一。每当我一个人在这里时，我喜欢假装其他人都死了。所以这挺好的。
Oh my God, it made me laugh all out. I spit out my water. I went to take a sip of water while we were listening to the deleted scene. It seemed like a safe time to take a sip of water, but that, that was so good. She pretends that everyone is dead. And at the end, they had me do a little smile like that. I was very delighted by this. Oh, that is incredible.
天哪，我笑得前仰后合。我把水都喷出来了。我们听被删减片段时，我正想喝口水。那似乎是个喝水的好时机，但是，那个真的太棒了。她假装所有人都死了。最后，他们让我做了一个那样的小微笑。我对这个感到非常高兴。哦，这太不可思议了。
Well Dwight's going to use this opportunity to call Michael and tattle. He is very, very mad. Michael is like, yeah, that makes total sense. Don't be weird. Everyone should go home. Why should they be there? I'm not there. Jim's not there.
好吧，德怀特要利用这个机会打电话给迈克尔打小报告。他非常非常生气。迈克尔的反应是，好吧，这完全合情合理。别大惊小怪的。每个人都应该回家。他们为什么要待在那儿？我不在。吉姆也不在。
Who cares? Right? Oh, Dwight is so sad. I know. But Dwight isn't going to go home. He has personal standards. He's going to work his day and he's going to dock everyone else's pay. He's going to try.
谁在乎呢？对吧？哦，德怀特太伤心了。我知道。但德怀特可不会回家。他有自己的原则。他要把这一天的工作做完，然后扣掉其他所有人的工资。他会去试一试的。
Look at the job fair. Pam has gone into her old art room to get a sheet of paper. I titled the scene brutal. Pam just wants one moment of her glory days, right? One moment. She's going to show the camera her piece of art. Surely it's still on the wall. Yeah.
看看招聘会。潘去了她以前的美术教室拿一张纸。我给这个场景起名为残酷。潘只想享受她辉煌岁月的某个瞬间，对吧？就一个瞬间。她要向摄像机展示她的艺术作品。它肯定还在墙上吧。对。
We got a lot of mail about this. People wanted to know what exactly is Pam looking for on the wall? Was it artwork? An award? They wanted to know if there was more to this scene and also just what was my take on this? I'll tell you, the idea was that when Pam was in school, a piece of her art was put on the wall on display and it was a big moment for her that she was very proud of. And she very, very quickly, as soon as she says maybe it's still there, realizes that
我们收到了很多关于这部分的邮件。人们想知道潘到底在墙上找什么？是艺术品？奖品吗？他们想知道这个场景是否还有更多内容，以及我对此有何看法。我来告诉你，当时的设想是，潘在学校的时候，她的一件艺术品被挂在墙上展出，对她来说那是一个非常自豪的重要时刻。而她非常非常快地，就在她说也许它还在那里的那一秒，意识到
like a decade has gone by since this moment that she was so proud of, probably the last moment that her art was held up for admiration because remember her art show didn't go great. And so she just has this crushing, like you said, brutal realization that a lot of time has gone by since she invested in this part of herself and she's quickly embarrassed and it has to just stuff it down and walk away. Well, it is exactly the same in the script as what you see in the episode. Yeah. In the script, it says, Pam comes up to a room that is labeled art room and goes inside
距离她感到如此自豪的这一刻已经过去了大约十年，这可能是她的艺术作品最后一次被高高举起供人赞赏，因为还记得她的艺术展并没有办得很顺利。因此她突然产生了那种崩溃感，就像你说的，残酷的现实，即自从她在这部分自我上投入精力以来已经过去了很长一段时间，她很快感到尴尬，不得不强压下这种情绪然后走开。好吧，这和你在剧集中看到的一模一样。对。在剧本里写着，潘走到一个标有美术教室的房间前，走了进去
and walks confidently to the supply desk. She finds a blank piece of paper and shows it to the camera. Pam says, my old art room, hey, I wonder if it's still here. She looks around at the walls that have some student artworks on them. Nope. They must have taken it down. Never mind. Yeah.
自信地走向材料桌。她找到一张白纸，向摄像机展示。潘说，我以前的美术教室，嘿，不知道它还在不在。她环顾四周，墙上挂着一些学生的艺术作品。没有。他们一定把它撤下来了。算了。对。
It's hard. It's hard to realize that you've put your hopes and dreams on hold. Yeah. And she does in this moment. You know, after all that, Pam brings this piece of paper to Michael and it's wrong. He wanted Dunder Mifflin card stock. He doesn't want this stupid random piece of paper. He sends her back to the office.
这很难。意识到自己把希望和梦想搁置了，这很难。对。而她在这一刻做到了。你知道，在那之后，潘把这张纸拿给迈克尔，结果拿错了。他想要的是邓德米夫林的卡片纸。他不要这张愚蠢的随手抽出来的纸。他把她赶回了办公室。
Yeah. He said, I don't want this Pendleton crap, which I looked up online and I couldn't find Pendleton paper. I did find Pendleton business cards. And he says, Pam, I want the ultra white card stock. Pam drives all the way back to Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. And she goes and gets the ultra white card stock out of the copier.
对。他说，我不要这帮彭德尔顿的垃圾，我在网上查了一下，但没找到彭德尔顿纸。我确实找到了彭德尔顿的名片。他说，潘，我想要超白卡片纸。潘一路开车回到了邓德米夫林。对。然后她去复印机里拿出了超白卡片纸。
Dwight looks puzzled and rightly so because I don't think that paper lives in the copier. Just gonna say. Well, let me tell you something about copiers, Angela. She pulls it from a specialty drawer in the copier, not from the main paper feed of the copier, which could have held copy paper, perhaps in our special drawer. You can select for when you want card stock. Well, I saw that she pulled it from the low drawer. Jenna, I saw that and not the other drawer, but I just think it would be on the shelf.
德怀特看起来很困惑，这是理所当然的，因为我不认为那种纸平时放在复印机里。我只想说这个。好吧，让我告诉你一些关于复印机的事，安吉拉。她是从复印机的一个专用抽屉里拿出来的，而不是从复印机的主进纸匣拿出来的，主进纸匣放的可能是复印纸，也许在我们那个特殊的抽屉里。当你想要卡片纸时，你可以进行选择。好吧，我看到她是从那个低一点的抽屉里拿的。珍娜，我看到了，不是另一个抽屉，但我只是觉得它应该在架子上。
So, well, if it had been on the shelf, it wouldn't have been as good of a shot between Dwight and Angela. So it had to come out of the copier. All right. That's the real reason. Okay. Fine. Well, we're about to go back to the golf course and there's a lot to talk about.
好吧，如果它在架子上，德怀特和安吉拉之间的镜头就不会那么精彩了。所以它必须从复印机里拿出来。好吧。这才是真正的理由。好吧。好吧。好了，我们马上要回到高尔夫球场了，有很多事情要聊。
I think maybe we should take a break and then we'll get into it after we've refreshed ourselves and emptied our bladders. I will wash my hands. If you need to know who Jenna's going to be at 70, you just heard her after we have refreshed ourselves and emptied our bladders. All right, guys, we'll be right back. All right. We are back.
我想也许我们应该休息一下，等我们休整好并排空膀胱后，再深入讨论。我要去洗手间。如果你想知道珍娜在70岁时会是什么样，你刚才听完我们休整好并排空膀胱之后的话就知道了。好了，伙计们，我们马上回来。好了。我们回来了。
Mr. McGuire is struggling with his ball. I like that. He's struggling with his ball in the sand trap. He can't get it out of the sand, Jenna. And he doesn't want anyone to help him. He wants to do it himself. Listen, Andy is just such a hot mess. He's having all of his rage issues.
麦圭尔先生正和他的高尔夫球较劲。我喜欢这样。他在沙坑里和球较劲。他怎么也把球从沙子里打不出来，珍娜。而且他不想让任何人帮他。他想自己来。听着，安迪真是个彻头彻尾的烂摊子。他一直在发飙。
He's got on his pants that have little pheasants on them. It's not going to make him happy when Jim gets a phone call from Pam while Andy's trying to swing. No, it is not. And Jim is really trying to recruit Mr. McGuire and McGuire is a big no. He's just like no, no, no. He just wants to play golf. Well, so does Andy, because he proposes that they race to the next hole.
他穿着印有小野鸡图案的裤子。当吉姆在安迪试图挥杆时接到潘的电话时，他可高兴不起来。不，绝对高兴不起来。而且吉姆真的在极力拉拢麦圭尔先生，而麦圭尔坚决不买账。他就是不，不，不。他只想打高尔夫。好吧，安迪也是这么想的，因为他提议他们比赛看谁先到下一个洞。
He hops in the golf cart and crashes it. He goes flying. The roof of the golf cart is ripped off. This is a major golf cart crash. I mean, I feel like this was a big stunt for us. It was. We got a lot of mail about it. People wanted to know, did Ed do this stunt?
他跳上高尔夫球车然后撞车了。他整个人飞了出去。高尔夫球车的车顶都被掀飞了。这是一次重大高尔夫球车撞击事故。我的意思是，我觉得这对我们来说是一个很大的特技。确实是。我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。人们想知道，这个特技是埃德本人做的吗？
No. No, no, no. Of course not. No, no, no, no. It was a stunt driver. We also got questions about everyone's actual golfing ability. Thomas V wants to know, did any of these guys actually play golf? Well, well, well, well, well, we will tell you, we know, I reached out to Ed and he said
不。不，不，不。当然不是。不，不，不，不。那是特技替身。我们还收到了关于每个人实际高尔夫水平的问题。托马斯·V想知道，这些人里真的有人会打高尔夫吗？好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧，好吧，我们会告诉你，我们知道的，我联系了埃德，他说
that before this episode, he had never been a golfer and that the show gave everybody lessons so that they could look like they knew what they were doing. And he really, really enjoyed it and he said since this episode, he has started playing recreationally, but he added it's just for fun, nothing like Brian Baumgartner. Brian is an athlete, you guys. We have talked about this before. He's a heck of a golfer. Oh, and he told me that his handicap is seven.
在拍摄这一集之前，他从来没打过高尔夫球，剧组给每个人都安排了课程，好让他们的样子看起来像是知道自己在做什么。他真的很享受，而且他说自从这一集之后，他开始把高尔夫作为娱乐来打，但他补充说这只是为了好玩，完全比不上布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳。布赖恩是个运动员，伙计们。我们以前讨论过这个。他是个高尔夫高手。哦，他告诉我他的差点是七。
That's really, really good, you guys. It's really good. He plays on these big fancy golf tournaments, you guys, like Michael Jordan has a golf tournament and Brian plays in it. Brian won the Derek Jeter Celebrity Invitational one year. Yeah. He goes to so many professional celebrity golf tournaments. He told me he has a room of suitcases because apparently there was a year where they gifted
这真的非常非常厉害，伙计们。非常厉害。他参加那些大型的高级高尔夫锦标赛，伙计们，比如迈克尔·乔丹有个高尔夫锦标赛，布赖恩就会去参加。布赖恩有一年还赢得了德里克·杰特名人邀请赛。对。他去了好多专业名人高尔夫锦标赛。他告诉我他有一个专门放行李箱的房间，因为显然有一年他们送了
every golfer a suitcase. Okay. He's like, I have so many suitcases, if you ever need a suitcase, that's crazy. Well, Brian also told me that they didn't play any actual golf while shooting these scenes. They hit a lot of balls, but they didn't have time to play much actual short game golf. You know, I bet he was bummed because he would have just schooled them all.
每个高尔夫球手一个行李箱。好吧。他说，我有太多的行李箱了，如果你需要行李箱，这太疯狂了。好吧，布赖恩还告诉我，他们在拍摄这些场景时并没有真的打高尔夫。他们击了很多球，但没有时间进行太多真实的短杆高尔夫游戏。你知道，我打赌他一定很失望，因为他本可以把他们全虐一遍。
I think so. And then I texted John. John told me that he absolutely loves playing golf, but he is horrible. I think he's no better than Jim. And he said that the reason Brian Baumgartner likes to golf with John is because that way Brian can really dominate. Oh, a little, little shade there at Brian. I guess so.
我也这么觉得。然后我给约翰发了短信。约翰告诉我他非常喜欢打高尔夫，但他技术极烂。我觉得他比吉姆好不到哪里去。他说布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳喜欢和约翰一起打高尔夫的原因是，这样布赖恩就能彻底占尽风头上。哦，对布赖恩有点小小的讽刺呢。我想是的。
Well, that is why it made sense to me that Kevin went because Kevin's not in sales. Kevin's an accountant, but I thought, I wonder if the writers were like, we need one guy that looks like he knows what he's doing. Well, Lee gave an interview after this episode aired because someone had asked that very question. Why Kevin? And he said after they picked who would go to the job fair, they had to look at who was left because remember Jim is trying to woo a client.
好吧，这就是为什么我觉得凯文去很合理，因为凯文不是销售人员。凯文是个会计，但我想，也许编剧们当时在想，我们需要一个看起来像是在状况内的人。好吧，李在这个剧集播出后接受了一次采访，因为有人问了那个具体的问题。为什么是凯文？他说，在他们选出谁去招聘会之后，他们不得不看看还剩下谁，因为别忘了吉姆正试图争取一个客户。
So we learned from this deleted scene that he brought Andy as his way of maybe being able to have this common enemy over the Dartmouth Cornell thing. And he brought Kevin maybe because he was the last best athletic choice in the office. It works. And I also think Kevin provided them with that extra storyline of the betting because that tracks for Kevin's character. Yeah. It's the time he's good at math.
所以我们从这个被删减的片段中了解到，他带上安迪可能是为了能在这个达特茅斯与康奈尔大学的话题上找到一个共同的敌人。他带上凯文可能是因为他是办公室里最后一个最好的运动型人选。这行得通。而且我也觉得凯文为他们带来了赌博这条额外的故事线，因为这很符合凯文的人设。对。这是他唯一擅长数学的时候。
Exactly. Well, back at the job fair, literally no one is interested in Dunder Mifflin. So Michael is going to have to revisit this idea of hiring Justin. Oh, and lady, there is a deleted scene that really explains why Michael is like, well, I guess I should reach out to Justin. There's sort of like a young hip like student that walks by and Michael chats him up and the guy is just being nice, right? The kid is being nice and Michael is just relentless and just wants him to be his best
没错。好吧，回到招聘会现场，真的没有人对邓德米夫林感兴趣。所以迈克尔不得不重新考虑雇佣贾斯汀的想法。哦，天哪，有一个被删减的片段真正解释了迈克尔为什么会说，好吧，我想我该联系一下贾斯汀。有点像那种年轻时髦的学生走过，迈克尔跟他套近乎，而那家伙人很好，对吧？那孩子人很好，而迈克尔却不依不饶，只希望他能成为自己最好的
friend. Like literally wants him to be his best friend. And the kid's like, okay, you know what? You're starting to creep me out. I was just trying to be nice. I don't want to work at your stupid paper company and Michael is devastated. And that is when he sort of has this moment of like, oh crap. Like if Justin's the only one that's interested.
朋友。简直是希望他成为自己最好的朋友。那孩子就说，好吧，你知道吗？你开始让我起鸡皮疙瘩了。我只是想表现得友善一点。我才不想在你们那个破纸业公司上班呢，迈克尔心碎了。正是在那个时候，他才有了那种恍然大悟的时刻，比如，哦该死。如果贾斯汀是唯一一个感兴趣的人。
Well, Michael brings Justin around and introduces him to everyone. But in the process of introducing Pam, he says, she'll do you. I mean, just kidding. But she has dated two guys in the office that we know of. And this leads to one of my favorite lines of the whole series. Is it what Michael says? Yes. Pam walks away and Michael says to Justin, listen, I wouldn't say.
好吧，迈克尔把贾斯汀带了过来并把他介绍给每个人。但在介绍潘的过程中，他说，她会伺候你的。我是说，开玩笑啦。但她和我们所知的办公室里的两个男人谈过恋爱。这 dẫn đến một trong những câu thoại yêu thích nhất của tôi trong cả series. Đó có phải là câu của Michael không? Đúng vậy. Pam bỏ đi và Michael nói với Justin, nghe này, tôi sẽ không nói câu này.
This to her face, but she's a wonderful person and a gifted artist. He wouldn't say it to her face. I feel like it's Oscars delivery of Oscars line that makes me laugh so hard because he goes, why wouldn't you say that to her face? I love that couple. That joke is so funny to me. So you guys, not only has Michael been, you know, in deleted scenes ditched by the hip cool kid, right?
trước mặt cô ấy, nhưng cô ấy là một người tuyệt vời và là một nghệ sĩ có tài. Anh ấy sẽ không nói điều đó trước mặt cô ấy ư? Tôi cảm thấy cách diễn đạt câu thoại của Oscar làm tôi cười rất lớn vì anh ấy nói, tại sao anh lại không nói điều đó trước mặt cô ấy? Tôi thích cặp đôi đó. Trò đùa đó thật hài hước đối với tôi. Vậy các bạn, Michael không chỉ bị, bạn biết đấy, trong các cảnh bị cắt, bị bỏ rơi bởi đứa trẻ ngầu lòi hợp thời, đúng không?
He then sees Justin being chatted up by the Air Force recruiter and in a deleted scene, Michael walks over and the Air Force recruiter is telling Justin how amazing he is, what a great asset he would be. And Michael is like, no, no, no, no, no, no, you need to work for us. He like gets really sort of aggressive and offers Justin this job. And that part makes it into the episode where Justin declines. But there's a whole other scene where the Air Force is really going after Justin. Wow.
Anh ấy sau đó thấy Justin đang trò chuyện với nhà tuyển dụng Không quân và trong một cảnh bị cắt, Michael bước tới và nhà tuyển dụng Không quân đang nói với Justin rằng anh ấy tuyệt vời thế nào, anh ấy sẽ là một tài sản lớn ra sao. Và Michael kiểu như, không, không, không, không, không, anh phải làm việc cho chúng tôi. Anh ấy kiểu như trở nên khá hung hăng và đề nghị công việc này cho Justin. Và phần đó đã lọt vào tập phim khi Justin từ chối. Nhưng có cả một cảnh khác nơi Không quân thực sự theo đuổi Justin. Chà.
Justin's two choices are the Air Force or Dunder Mifflin paper. Those are real different sides of the pendulum there. Very different. And Michael says to the Air Force recruiter, you're telling me this guy could be a fighter pilot? He's like, yes, he can. And Michael's like, oh, my God. Well a woman comes to the microphone and announces that the job fair is coming to an end.
贾斯汀有两个选择，要么去空军，要么去丹德米夫林纸业公司。这可以说是两个截然不同的方向。非常不一样。迈克尔对空军招聘人员说，你是说这家伙可以当战斗机飞行员？对方说，是的，他可以。迈克尔听了说，哦，天哪。接着，一个女人走到麦克风前宣布，招聘会即将结束。
Yes. And that woman was played by our female stand in Lori Sox. Yes. If you go to 15 minutes, 58 seconds, you will see Lori. We loved Lori and her husband, Steven, their husband and wife, stand in duo. They were with us for years. They were like family. Well, you might remember Steven because he was featured at the dinner table in Benihana
没错。那个女人由我们的女替身演员洛瑞·索克斯（Lori Sox）扮演。对。如果你快进到15分58秒，你就会看到洛瑞。我们很喜欢洛瑞和她的丈夫史蒂文，他们是一对夫妻替身搭档。他们和我们在一起多年。他们就像家人一样。对了，你可能还记得史蒂文，因为他在《班尼哈纳》圣诞节那一集里出现过，坐在餐桌旁。
Christmas. Yes. And so from time to time, they pop up in episodes. And like Angela said, these guys really are like family to us. Steven and Lori have two kids. And Lori had Sophia before I had Isabelle and Jenna, she was my person. I went to, I'd be like, Lori, I'm feeling this or I'm doing this or I had a question about breastfeeding.
没错。所以他们会不时在剧集中客串。正如安吉拉所说，这些人对我们来说真的就像家人一样。史蒂文和洛瑞有两个孩子。在我生伊abelle之前，洛瑞就生了索菲亚。珍娜，她就是我的心灵支柱。每当我有什么感受、在做什么，或者对母乳喂养有疑问时，我就会去找洛瑞。
And she was just always there to sort of guide me through being a working mom. It was Lori and Malora. They were the two moms I went to. Yes. Yeah. Both of her kids were born while we shot the office. So her daughter, Sophia is 13. I know her and Isabelle are very close in age.
她总是陪伴在我身边，指导我如何成为一个职场妈妈。找的就是洛瑞和玛洛拉。她们是我求助过的两位伟大的母亲。没错。是的。我们拍《办公室》期间，她的两个孩子都出生了。所以她的女儿索菲亚现在13岁了。我知道她和伊abelle年纪差不多大。
And their son, Liam, who just turned 10 years old, I cannot believe he's 10. I know. Passage of time. You see it in your children. Well, their son, Liam has Down syndrome. And Steven and Lori actually have this amazing podcast and we want to shout it out. It's called If We Knew Then and it is a Down syndrome advocacy podcast for parents. Our goal is to reach as many parents and prospective parents as possible.
还有他们的儿子利亚姆，刚满10岁，真不敢相信他10岁了。我懂的。时光飞逝。在孩子身上就能看出来。对了，他们的儿子利亚姆患有唐氏综合症。史蒂文和洛瑞其实有一个非常棒的播客，我们想为它打个call。它叫《如果我们当时就知道》（If We Knew Then），这是一个面向父母的唐氏综合症倡导播客。我们的目标是尽可能多地接触到父母和准父母。
The podcast features interviews and positive information about Down syndrome advocacy and inclusion. You guys definitely check it out. Check it out. Again, it's called If We Knew Then. It is so good. I just listened to their episode where they talk about the week that they had Liam in the hospital and everything they were journeying through in that moment.
该播客以采访以及关于唐氏综合症倡导和包容的积极信息为特色。大家一定要去听听。去看看吧。再次强调，它叫《如果我们当时就知道》。真的非常棒。我刚刚听了他们的一期节目，里面谈到利亚姆住院的那一个星期，以及他们当时经历的一切。
And they are so kind, relatable, thoughtful, caring people. I really enjoyed their conversation. We're just so happy to share about their podcast. We're going to put them in our stories. We'll put a swipe up to your podcast, guys. And Lori and Steven, we just love you guys so much. It is so fun for me to see them pop up in these episodes. We saw them every day at work, so we're excited that they've been memorialized in the episode
他们是非常善良、平易近人、体贴、有爱心的人。我真的很喜欢他们的对话。我们很高兴能分享他们的播客。我们会把链接放到我们的快拍里。大家可以上滑直达你们的播客。洛瑞和史蒂文，我们真的非常爱你们。看到他们出现在这些剧集里，对我来说太有趣了。我们每天在工作时都能见到他们，所以很高兴他们能在剧集里被记录下来，
for everybody. Yes, and Steven is still part of that very competitive fantasy football league of the office cast and crew. Yes. Lee told me that actually Steven is responsible for the draft pick numbers every year. And there is a tradition where he makes a video of Sophia and Liam reaching into a bowl and picking out the numbers for the order of the draft. That's how all these guys find out their pick number is from Sophia and Liam every year.
分享给每个人。是的，史蒂文依然是《办公室》演员和剧组那个竞争非常激烈的梦幻足球联盟的一员。没错。李告诉我，其实史蒂文每年都负责选秀顺位的抽签数字。有个传统是，他会拍一段视频，让索菲亚和利亚姆把手伸进碗里，抓出选秀顺序的数字。大家每年都是通过索菲亚和利亚姆来得知自己的选秀顺位的。
I love our office family. I love it. Well, you guys, Michael's getting desperate and he's going to do that classic thing that Michael does where he has to go up on stage and take the microphone. Yeah. He wants to know if anyone wants to intern at Dunder Mifflin. He says they do not offer college credit and they cannot give you any sort of pay, but it's a super fun work environment.
我太爱我们的办公室大家庭了。我太喜欢了。好了，各位，迈克尔开始感到绝望了，他要做出迈克尔式的经典举动了——走上台去抢麦克风。是的。他想知道有没有人想在丹德米夫林实习。他说他们不提供学分，也没有任何薪水，但工作环境超级有趣。
Anyone? Show of hands? Anyone? Yeah. It's amazing. I mean, security comes pretty quickly. Yes. I know with Lori like marching right in front.
有人吗？举手看看？有人吗？对啊。太惊人了。我是说，保安很快就上来了。是的。我知道洛瑞就大步走在最前面。
Yeah, it's not going to go great. They're going to leave with no interns. They're going to leave with no interns and no one ever wanting to work there. Thanks, Michael. Speaking of Dunder Mifflin and working there, we should probably catch you up on how it's going between little Dwight and Angela back at the office. First they had to make some copies. I took a screen grab of this scene of us making copies.
对，事情不会太顺利。他们最后会一个实习生都招不到。他们会落得个一个实习生都没有，而且没人愿意在那里工作的下场。谢谢你，迈克尔。说到丹德米夫林和在那里工作，我们大概该跟你们聊聊小德怀特和安吉拉在办公室进展得怎么样了。首先他们得复印一些文件。我截取了我们复印时的这个场景。
It really perfectly shows how much they had to crop me out. Oh yeah, your shoulders up. I know. When I say something that I noticed about this scene, okay, there's only two people in the office. Mm-hmm. Apparently you need to make copies at the same time. So there's a line.
它真的很完美地展示了他们必须把我裁掉多少。哦，对，只剩你的肩膀往上了。我知道。我要说一下我在这场戏中注意到的一点，好吧，办公室里只有两个人。嗯。显然你们需要同时复印。所以排起了队。
Mm-hmm. There's also a copier in the annex. I think Angela just wanted to stand close to him. I think she did too. I think her heart is melting a little. You know, it's taken her a bit. He did freeze her cat. So she's had a lot to unpack there, but I think she's softening.
嗯。附楼里也有一台复印机。我觉得安吉拉只是想离他近一点。我也这么觉得。我觉得她的心有点融化了。你知道的，这花了一点时间。他毕竟把她的猫给冰冻了。所以她有很多心结要解开，但我认为她正在软化。
Well, Dwight's gonna sneeze, and Angela's gonna say bless you. I know. I think it's the beginning, the beginning of the Angela and Dwight rekindling. And I have more evidence. If you needed more, what? As they're leaving for the day, Dwight holds the door. He waits and holds the door for Angela, and she says thank you. I know.
接着德怀特打了个喷嚏，安吉拉说了声“保重”。我知道。我认为这是安吉拉和德怀特重修旧好的开始。我还有更多证据。如果你还需要的话，什么？在他们下班离开时，德怀特扶着门。他等着并为安吉拉扶着门，然后安吉拉说了谢谢。我知道。
I mean, this is in their language, like this is on again almost. Oh, yeah. They're about to go to the warehouse and hook up. Right. Exactly. Exactly. That's about to happen. Well, back at the golf course, turns out Kevin did okay.
我是说，这简直是他们的语言，感觉他们快要复合了。哦，是的。他们马上就要去仓库亲热了。没错。完全正确。这马上就要发生了。好了，回到高尔夫球场，凯文表现得还不错。
He wants to collect his money from all of his winnings. But Mr. McGuire says, no, no, no, we'll start a tab because I'm gonna play more golf with you guys. Hmm. We'll play more golf with them, but he refuses still to give Jim his business. But Jim isn't gonna take no for an answer. No, he's gonna throw himself in front of this man's car. Yeah.
他想拿回他赢来的钱。但麦奎尔先生说，不，不，不，我们先记账，因为我还要跟你们打更多的高尔夫球。嗯。我们会跟他们打更多高尔夫，但他仍然拒绝把生意交给吉姆。但吉姆可不会接受被拒绝。不，他要直接挡在这个人的车前。对。
I found it a little off-putting. Jim said he said he would call him every day until he gave him his business. Well, it works on Mr. McGuire. I feel like Jim is using Dwight's sales tactics. He's certainly exercising persistence, and I guess it pays off. Mr. McGuire says, okay, there you go. It worked. And they're gonna come back to the office and they're gonna be drinking some beers toasting
我觉得这有点让人反感。吉姆说他会天天打电话给对方，直到把生意交给他。不过这招对麦奎尔先生挺管用。我觉得吉姆在运用德怀特的销售策略。他确实表现出了坚持不懈的精神，我想这有了回报。麦奎尔先生说，好吧，那就这样吧。成功了。然后他们回到办公室，喝着啤酒庆祝
their good fortune as Michael and Pam and Oscar and Daryl returned from the job fair. And Pam is like, you did it. You closed the deal. You sold it and she runs up and they smooch, then they shake hands because they're like awkward and then they completely make out in front of everyone. Angela, I remember shooting this scene. PDA, awkward. We were kissing for so long.
他们的好运气，与此同时，迈克尔、帕姆、奥斯卡和达里尔从招聘会回来了。帕姆说，你做到了。你谈成这笔生意了。你把它卖出去了，然后她跑过去，他们亲吻了一下，接着又握了手，因为他们觉得有点尴尬，然后他们在所有人面前当众热吻。安吉拉，我记得拍摄这场戏的情景。当众秀恩爱，好尴尬。我们吻了好久。
It felt like a long time. And it's not even hardly on camera. Now that I see the episode, you're like, dang it. But part of this big kiss was because we had this shorter season from the writer's strike and we didn't get to advance a lot of jammy storylines after all, right? They had this whole plan that they were gonna move in together. So we're near the end of the season and we had to throw in big jam moment, right? So here it is.
感觉持续了很长时间。而且镜头里几乎都没怎么播出来。现在我看到这一集，你会想，该死。但这个大吻的一部分原因是因为编剧罢工导致这一季变短了，我们最终没能推进很多“咸鱼”CP（Jam）的剧情，对吧？他们原本一整套计划是打算同居的。所以差不多到了季末，我们必须塞进一个重磅的“咸鱼”高光时刻，对吧？所以它就来了。
You're gonna get to see them have a big smooch. This is, I think, the biggest smooch of the series, really. It's the longest smooch. I would say the biggest, most epic smooch was Casino Night. That was not as long as this. Well, that's what I was about to say. I feel like it was a big pivotal smooch, but this is the longest smooch. Yeah.
你们会看到他们来了一个大大的热吻。我认为这真的是整部剧里最大的热吻。这是最长的吻。如果要说最大、最史诗级的热吻，应该是赌场之夜那一幕。那个没有这个吻这么长。好吧，这就是我正要说的。我觉得那是一个关键的转折点之吻，但这确实是最长的吻。是的。
And it was very, very funny. Angela, this is my question. Was it in the script for Michael to say kiss or kiss or good? Because I could not get through that. We were laughing so hard and my memory is that Steve did that as an improvisation. It's in the script. Oh my gosh. It's in the script.
而且非常非常搞笑。安吉拉，这是我的问题。剧本里写的是让迈克尔说“亲她”或者“亲得好”吗？因为我当时根本演不下去。我们笑得太厉害了，我的记忆是史蒂夫那是即兴发挥。剧本里就是这么写的。哦天哪。剧本里确实写了。
It says Michael has gotten very close to Jim and Pam and is watching them kiss from really far too close. And Michael says, yeah, kiss her. Kiss her good. It was very, very funny. And you can see when John and I separate that my face is a little red. It's a little chased from so much kissing. We had to do this scene so many times.
上面写着，迈克尔离吉姆和帕姆非常近，并且从近得离谱的距离看着他们亲吻。然后迈克尔说，对，亲她。狠狠地亲她。非常非常搞笑。当我和约翰分开时，你可以看到我的脸有点红。因为亲了太多次，脸都被蹭红了。我们这场戏拍了超多次。
And you can see, I think, John had a little stubble. A little stubble? Well, do you want to hear what was in the script? Yeah. Angela and Dwight were there for this moment. What? Yes. And while the guys are drinking beers, Angela shishes them.
而且你们可以看到，我觉得约翰当时有点胡茬。有点胡茬？好吧，你们想听听剧本里原本是怎么写的吗？想。安吉拉和德怀特当时也在这个场景里。什么？是的。当这几个家伙在喝啤酒时，安吉拉冲他们做出了“嘘”的手势。
And then Angela and Dwight have their moment later in the script when they leave and Dwight holds open the door and all that. But how awkward would it have been for Dwight and Angela to be there too? I'm glad they changed that. Yeah. That was a good move. Yeah. We need more, Angela, judgment, Pam doesn't need more.
然后剧本里稍后还有安吉拉和德怀特的时刻，就是他们离开时德怀特扶着门之类的。但是，如果德怀特和安吉拉也在场，那该有多尴尬啊？我很高兴他们改掉了。是的。那是个好决定。是的。我们需要更多安吉拉式的审视，帕姆可不需要更多了。
The last scene of this episode is a flashback back to the job fair. This is going to set us up for Pam's storyline in season five. We're going to plant some seeds here. You see Pam go up to a booth for a graphic design firm and she wants to fill out an application. Yes. And you guys might notice that the graphic design guy is played by Nelson Franklin. He's going to come back in season six as the IT guy. I have a little fun tidbit about Nelson.
这一集的最后一个场景是回到招聘会的闪回。这将为帕姆在第五季的剧情做铺垫。我们要在这里埋下一些伏笔。你可以看到帕姆走向一家平面设计公司的展位，她想填一份申请表。是的。大家可能会注意到，那个平面设计小哥是由纳尔逊·富兰克林（Nelson Franklin）扮演的。他将在第六季回归扮演IT男。关于纳尔逊，我有一个有趣的小花絮。
I know what it is. Tell us. Nelson and I were co-stars on a new show for Netflix, hashtag BlackAF. We played writers in the writer's room with Kenya Barris and Rashida Jones placed Kenya's wife, Joya, and Ken Quapas directed us. It was like a whole office reunion. That show is so funny. Your writer's room scenes are so funny.
我知道是什么。告诉我们吧。纳尔逊和我曾是Netflix新剧《#黑人当道》（BlackAF）的联合主演。我们在肯尼亚·巴里斯（Kenya Barris）的编剧室里饰演编剧，而拉什达·琼斯（Rashida Jones）饰演肯尼亚的妻子乔亚（Joya），肯·夸帕斯（Ken Quapas）执导了我们这部剧。这简直就像是一次办公室大团聚。那部剧太搞笑了。你们在编剧室的戏份太好笑了。
Manjula, your character is amazing in that show. I play yet another miserable woman. You're so good at it. Oh, thanks. I loved all the writer's room bits, you know, because you and I, we've observed writer's rooms over the years and it was really fun to kind of play out some of that shtick. Well, Nelson is amazing. He also had a regular recurring role on Veep.
安吉拉，你在那部剧里的角色太棒了。我演的又是一个痛苦的女人。你太擅长演这个了。哦，谢谢。我喜欢所有的编剧室桥段，你知道的，因为你和我这些年来观察过很多编剧室，把其中一些老套路表演出来真的很有趣。话说纳尔逊太棒了。他还在《副总统》（Veep）中出演了常驻常规角色。
He had a regular role on Blackish and it's true. He's going to come back in season six and I don't know how they did that. I'm going to figure it out. When we get to season six, I'm going to tell you it's a little bit of a bewitched moment, isn't it? It is. It's like, which Darren is this? I will point out one thing.
他在《喜新不厌旧》（Black-ish）中也有常规角色，真的。他将在第六季回归，我不知道他们是怎么做到的。我要弄清楚。等我们到了第六季，我会告诉你们，这有点像《家有仙妻》（Bewitched）式的时刻，对吧？确实如此。就像是，这个是哪个达伦？我指出一件事。
Nelson joins our very tall male cast member club. He is six foot five. Every scene I have to be in with him, he has to be seated. Well, he's really good in this scene with Pam. You know, he kind of explains to her, you just need like basic knowledge of what's going on, all of these programs that Pam has no knowledge of at all. And then he says, you know, you could probably get training somewhere. Do you like an adult education class, but the best place to go, and this is where we
纳尔逊加入了我们的高个男演员俱乐部。他身高六英尺五英寸（约1.96米）。我跟他演每一场戏都必须是坐着的。好吧，他在跟帕姆的这场戏里演得真好。你知道，他有点向她解释，你只需要对正在发生的事情有基本的了解，而这些软件帕姆完全一无所知。然后他说，你知道的，你或许可以在什么地方进行培训。比如上个成人教育班，但最好的去处——这就是我们
plant the seeds for next season, the best place to learn about graphic design are programs in New York or Philadelphia. And she's like, got it, New York or Philadelphia. Yep. What is Pam going to do? We'll find out. We will, and that was job fair. And lady, I can't believe I'm saying this, but up next is the finale of season four.
为下一季埋下伏笔的地方——学习平面设计的最佳去处是纽约或费明白了，纽约或费城。Yep。帕姆要做什么？我们拭目以待。会的，这就是招聘会。天哪，真不敢相信我要这么说，接下来就是第四季的大结局了。
I know already. Thank you guys so much for sending in your questions and comments. Thanks so much to our cast members for letting us bug them about golf and pumpkin out and everything else we hit them up for. Yeah, they're amazing. They're the best. And Lori and Steven socks, we love you guys. We'll be putting a swipe up to their podcast if we knew then see you next week guys.
我知道，时间过得真快。非常感谢大家发来问题和评论。非常感谢我们的演员们容忍我们对高尔夫、南瓜等各种事情的纠缠。是的，他们太棒了。他们是最好的。洛瑞和史蒂文·索克斯，我们深爱着你们。我们将把链接放到他们的播客《如果我们当时就知道》上。下周见，各位。
Have a fantastic week. See you then. Thank you for listening to office ladies. Office ladies is produced by your wolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkin. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton.
祝大家度过美好的一周。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西为您倾情制作。我们的节目执行制片人为科迪·费舍尔。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。
For ad-free versions of office ladies, go to Stitcher Premium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问 Stitcher Premium.com。如需免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用优惠码 office。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。